your biggest fear of getting robbed an  ATM is probably from the person queuing  behind you but soon it might be from a  hacker sitting behind a computer unknown  to many nearly all the world's cash  machines are operated by microsoft  windows XP the same software that runs  on many computers it's also 12 years old  on the 8th of April Microsoft is pulling  its support for the aging software in  favor of newer programs this could mean  a higher risk of digital attack for  those customers which haven't entered  into special contracts Microsoft  wouldn't tell us how many hadn't won ATM  maker said the cost to upgrade could be  in the thousands of dollars per machine  the question is whether an ATM operator  will put a price on your security